una marea morada en las calles de méxico
miles de mujeres en la capital y en
diferentes puntos del país se
movilizaron una vez más contra los
feminicidios están indignadas por la
muerte de deban y escobar la joven de 18
años asesinada en nuevo león el segundo
estado con más feminicidios registrados
durante el año ya son 22 casos en el
primer trimestre del 2022 según los
datos proporcionados por el propio
gobierno y al menos 52 mujeres están
desaparecidas porque las autoridades no
hacen lo que tienen que hacer con tiempo
y nómina
cuando hay una desaparición para ellas
son ausentes
y todavía siguen con el argumento que
tenemos que esperar unos 72 horas para
dar con su localización
como que en vez de ir avanzando en una
fiscalía especializada desaparecidos
parece que vamos para atrás no para
adelante su reclamos también por la ola
de violencia contra las mujeres en todo
el territorio el caso de de baní agudizó
la indignación en el país azteca
encontraron su cuerpo el pasado jueves
en un tanque de agua de un motel cerca
de donde desapareció el 9 de abril sus
padres la velaron consternados pero han
sido enfáticos en denunciar el caso de
su hija
rodolfo salinas
porque la persona
que
esté minisitio de la joven sólo ha
resaltado una situación que es cada vez
más difícil de silenciar
en mexico asesinan a 11 mujeres cada día
y 7 desaparecen según denuncian las
organizaciones feministas